de l'offre et la demande,
une pratique de plus en plus
répandue dans le milieu du sport
pour maximiser les profits.
Charlotte Dumoulin s'est
penchée sur la question.
- Ça peut passer de 120-130
à 300-400 plus on descend
vers le bas.
- Nathacha et Patrice Savard ont
été surpris par les variations
de prix entre les billets
de l'Omnium Banque Nationale.
Prenons ces deux sièges de
la section 112 du court central
pour la séance de jeudi midi.
Ils coûtent 544 $ la veille,
tandis que les deux mêmes places
pour les parties du vendredi
à la même heure se vendent
à 790 $ en quarts de finales.
Et ils peuvent encore augmenter
dans les prochaines heures.
C'est ce qu'on appelle
des prix dynamiques.
EUGÈNE LAPIERRE, directeur,
Omnium Banque Nationale
- On a suivi ce qui se fait
ailleurs, en fait,
dans la plupart des grands
spectacles sportifs. Il y a
un algorithme qui calcule avec
le nombre de billets restant,
puis ça va jusqu'à un maximum.
- Comme les billets d'avion,
les prix des places au tournoi
de tennis à Montréal augmentent
selon l'offre et la demande.
Sur une même rangée,
les spectateurs peuvent payer
leurs billets à des prix
très variés.
PHILIP MERRIGAN, prof., Départ.
sciences économiques, UQAM
- On marche un peu sur un fil
de fer. Même si, à court terme,
on peut avoir des revenus
très intéressants, à long terme,
ça pourrait décourager
notre clientèle.
- Voyant les prix de dernière
minute, Stéphane Langlois
préfère amener ses enfants
aux parties de tennis plus
abordables sur les terrains
secondaires, et il n'est pas
le seul.
- C'est assez dispendieux.
Quand on est allés voir
le Canadien, ça coûtait
moins cher que ça.
- On a pris le court Rogers,
parce que c'est sûr que
le court central, je trouvais ça
vraiment cher pour des places
qui étaient très, très hautes.
- Le directeur des
Internationaux du Canada défend
la stratégie de vente de billets
à des prix dynamiques.
- C'est bon pour nous, c'est bon
pour le développement du sport,
parce qu'on remet tous
les profits de l'Omnium Banque
Nationale pour le développement
du tennis et des jeunes.
- Les prix fixes pour
les événements sportifs seront
de moins en moins la norme.
Si certains sont mécontents,
beaucoup d'autres acceptent
cette nouvelle réalité.
À preuve, la partie
avec Félix Auger-Aliassime
affiche complet.
Ici Charlotte Dumoulin,
Radio-Canada, Montréa